Everybody seems to think that Obama is
in his heart,
an atheist in India's hardest skeptic.
The church he belonged to in Chicago is
a whack job church.
It's about equal to Payton's church.
Granted,
he hasn't been as religious as do we
know?
Do we know off the top of our heads,
the most religious president in history,
in terms of references referencing to
God references to God and in terms of
appearing in churches who the most
religious president history was.
It's an interesting answer and I get
this information from NPR,
so it's probably not slanted in the way
you'd think.
The most religious president in history,
in terms of appearances in churches and
mentions of the Bible was Clinton.
Bill Clinton is the most religious
president we've had.
He Beats George Bush,
hands down,
and he beats Carter,
who you know was a born again Christian.
He beats him hands down.
So Obama does that too.
I mean to the nine slash 11 thing.
Maybe appropriately he read from the
Bible,
but you have two choices with Obama.
You either believe that he is a man of
Christ who prays for decisions in the
White House,
which he said he was,
or you think he's a liar.
And I'm surprised by the number of
atheists,
pre thinkers that support Obama and
their argument is essentially he's lying
about being religious cause you have to
do that to be elected.
Uh,
I'm not happy with either one of those.
I mean,
Obama is wicked smart.
He's a wicked good talker.
There is no doubt in my mind that his
heart is in the right place.
Unfortunately,
I think that about almost every
president we've had,
but I think he wants to do good.
I don't think there's any malicious
quality to them at all,
but I think it's some sense he's a
believer or he's a liar.
So one to 10.
I rate them pretty high on the
skepticism a maybe a six or a seven,
but I rate them that way because
somewhere in my heart I think he might
be lying about being religious and
that's horrible.
It's a horrible reason to like somebody.
I like him because he may be a liar.
Mirabelle Michele Bachmann's blast for
me is greater than anything I've ever
accomplished.
Uh,
I have tried with friends to say the
most blasphemous his sentence I can
possibly say,
and it does not come close to the
blasphemy of Michele Bachmann saying
that earthquakes and hurricanes were the
way God was trying to get the attention
of politicians.
I cannot imagine a serious religious
person reading that quote or hearing
that quote and saying,
yeah,
right on.
It is solid cystic.
It is opportunistic.
It is cynical.
It is deep and it is wrong.
And it is an insult to religious people
everywhere.
For an atheist,
it's a,
it's a burlesque.
It's a little bit of a joke.
You can dismiss her,
but I can't see it as an atheist.
I see it from through my father's eyes.
You know,
my father was a Christian his whole
life,
and if he had heard Michele Bachmann say
that he would have looked away from the
TV,
the idea that you would lightly state
that people were suffering and dying in
order to,
to prove that God was on the side of one
politician is sickening.
The only reason that Bachman and Rick
Perry are able to say this stuff is
because of a magic word,
and this magic word is Christian,
and if you look back in history,
the word Christian doesn't really appear
in the way we use it today until the
anti abortion debate in the sixties when
you had 1890 end of the 19th century,
your top three highest paid speakers.
The highest paid speakers were atheist
speaking about atheism.
Robert Ingersoll number one,
Mark Twain,
number two,
Huxley.
Number three.
Ingersoll was the,
uh,
the,
the great infidel,
the great skeptic,
be a theist.
Mark Twain,
of course.
And these are people speaking on.
He was not reading from,
it was not reading from Oxfam.
He was reading from letters from Earth.
He was reading atheist stuff and Huxley,
Darwin's a pit bull,
I guess bulldog at that time,
I think if it has been,
but there was a real sense of atheism
being an important point.
They were invited to the White House.
And the reason was that Catholics were
terrified of baptists who were terrified
of pentecostals or terrified of
Lutherans who were terrified of
evangelicals.
The whole list.
There wasn't a feeling of Christian.
The founding fathers were very afraid of
baptists taking over from the
pentecostals.
Everybody was afraid of the Catholics.
So you had this divided thing.
If we still had that,
if we still were dividing people by sex,
like we should be sex like we should be.
One of the largest groups in this
country would be atheists by the USA
Today poll,
I think it was 22 percent,
20 percent even the lowest polls put it
at eight.
Okay.
The next highest would be Catholics and
they'd be knocking around 20.
You know,
then you've got all your divided up
categories.
And then abortion happens.
A legalized abortion.
And some very smart people.
Very forward thinking.
People decided we can never fight
abortion if it's the Catholics fighting
the Protestants and finding the
baptists.
Pentecostals fight it.
We have to get them under one tent.
And there's a great book on this called
the history of free thought that these
are not my ideas.
They pull this tent together and they
kind of create the word Christian and
then Carter with born again.
Christian really helps with the word
Christian.
So what they've really done is they've
taken very different philosophies.
I mean Catholicism and Protestantism.
Protestantism are very different
philosophies,
very different,
you know,
and they've pulled it together to make
this term Christian,
which are people that don't agree at all
and they say,
I'm doing a Christian message.
So Michelle Bachmann and Rick Perry just
40 years ago really recently would have
been terrified to speak about their God
and their church because the second they
said they were baptist,
the second they said they were
pentecostal,
the second they said they were Lutheran,
all the other people fall away.
But now they've got this magic word
Christian.
And I am helping make it worse because
by using the word atheist,
I am separating that even more from
Christian.
I'm doing a broader umbrella and I'm
making theist,
atheist.
And if you do,
theist,
atheist,
the thesis when completely,
you know,
what I should be doing.
If I were a,
a,
uh,
a political thinker,
if I were someone that was interested in
movements,
which I'm not,
I'm against them.
If I wasn't for individual thinking,
I would be one of those people who was
saying using a term like free thinker or
open minded and I will be gathering this
umbrella that included,
um,
uh,
people who self identify as agnostic or
atheist against organized religion.
I would get the wiccans in there.
I would get as many people as possible
and I could probably pump that up to 25
percent.
And then I would be also saying,
well,
you know,
the Muslims are very different from the
Jews who are very different from the
Catholics who are very different from
all of that.
But what's going to happen?
And,
uh,
because I'm not interested in tactical
play,
but rather in telling the truth,
we're going to get theist,
atheist.
But you can imagine,
we can imagine in 1965 a baptist talking
baptist politician talking about
religion and where they go to church,
if they have to use word baptist,
it's using the word Christian that
allows this craziness to happen.
Also,
because I am
an optimist,
to the point of being incorrect,
to the point of not being realistic.
That's what flushes over me.
It's what I feel in my heart is
optimism.
I tend to go with something Christopher
Hitchens said,
I don't remember where he said it could
have even been in personal conversation.
I don't know,
but I'm hitchens said that what we're
seeing with this incredible,
crazy religious stuff is the death
throws.
I mean,
since nine slash 11,
a free thinking.
Atheism is growing so quickly because of
the Internet and people who were seeing
it first with those who are called.
And I realized this is a racist term,
but it's easiest one to use.
So please forgive me.
Uh,
Gypsy's.
We're seeing it with the amish.
We're seeing it with the citrix.
Uh,
all the groups that try to stay as a
subset of America and keep their own
traditions are going away.
And Elvis chipped away at them and malls
chipped away at them,
but the Internet is going to take them
down.
It's just too hard to keep your children
cloistered.
They're going to hear Katy Perry.
There's just no way to stop it.
They're going to see a video like this.
You know,
once you've gotten on the Internet to
see Katy Perry,
it's not hard to fall over to the big
thing.
It's the same keyboard.
It's the same screen.
It's the same everything and those that
information gets out there and I think
that everybody knows that and everybody
feels that so that those who are
religious,
you're seeing a a,
a desperate,
terrified clawing,
and that's the only way you can explain
Michele Bachmann and Rick Perry is the
combination of desperation coupled with
the magic protective word of Christian.
The problem is a movement of individuals
is not going to have the muscle of a
cohesive movement of people who believe
they're right and I'm not willing to lie
to fight them.
I want individuals who disagree on
everything and I want us to learn to
band together for freedom band together
in order to be different,
and that's a much harder thing to sell,
but it's all that matters.
So we have to do it.
Mitt Romney is wearing crazy underwear.
He's wearing magic underwear.
He is under his pants.
He is wearing magic underwear,
magic underwear,
and he believes that a convicted con man
got golden tablets that no one else
could see and sat with an angel to find
out that the original Jews of the Bible
were living in North America.
Crazy,
crazy,
but just more modern,
not more crazy than other religions,
not more crazy than Islam,
you know,
with,
uh,
not more crazy than virgin births.
And resurrections,
uh,
not more crazy than any of that stuff.
It fascinates me
that you can have the Bible belt and you
can have a court trial,
and we've seen this.
I'm going to use it hypothetically,
but you'll know the specifics I'm
talking about.
I just don't want to talk about that
kind of pain directly.
It's too unpleasant for me.
But hypothetically,
if the Bible belt where you can have a
born again,
Christian judge,
I believe the Bible is the literal word
of God.
There were talking snakes.
They were talking snakes and virgin
births,
burning bushes,
and Abraham being willing to kill his
son for God.
He believes that the jury is made up of
12 people who let's say 10 of them
believed that and to have them believe
that,
but a little less,
you're prosecuting attorney believes
that the people that are sitting in the
courtroom believed that these are all
people that know each other in church
and the person on the witness stand says
that she killed her three children in
cold blood because God told her to
and every single person in the courtroom
decides whether she is guilty or not
guilty by reason of insanity.
Those are the two choices they way and
nobody,
not the defense attorney,
not the judge,
not the jury people,
not the people in the gallery,
not one person stands up and goes,
maybe God told her to.
It's.
It's less weird than the talking snake.
Maybe God told her to and in this
country which they say over and over
again is founded on Christian values and
I'll give them that founded on Christian
values.
Okay,
it is fine.
This country founded on Christian values
has guilty not guilty,
not guilty by reason of insanity.
End of list.
There is nothing that says not guilty
because God told me to and why?
Why isn't that there?
Why isn't this country allowing them,
the court system,
someone to go on the witness stand and
go,
snake walk up to me.
Snake opened his mouth.
Snake said,
go into Mcdonald's.
Pull out an eight K,
15 killed 10 people walk back out.
Snake told me that it's that snake
there.
He's not talking anymore.
I throw myself on the mercy of the
court.
Aren't you all good Christians?
Don't you believe in the miracles of the
Bible?
You're seeing one now
and that's.
That's the part that amazes me is that
kind of stuff.
So Mitt Romney comes along and at some
level doesn't he know what he believes
is crazy at some level is any going.
Weren't Jews in North America?
You know that's not where the garden of
Eden was.
Doesn't that go through his mind?
And that's the part of that whole thing
that kills me.
If Mitt Romney,
he really believes what he says,
he believes he is bugged,
nutty bat shit crazy and he's not
bugged.
Nutty batshit crazy.
He's the same as Obama.
If Obama believes what he was being
taught in that church in Chicago,
okay,
he is bat shit crazy and Obama is
demonstrative.
Lee Not batshit crazy.
So we have this weird deal we make with
all the politicians where we say you can
say you believe bug nutty bat shit,
crazy shit,
and we'll shrug it off because you're
clearly not bugged.
Nutty batshit crazy.
And all I want out of our politicians is
for them to just say,
you know,
a lot of the religious stuff I'm talking
about is bugged,
duddy bad shit.
Crazy.
But I'm not because I don't think any of
these men and women are crazy and I'll
even give you Michele Bachmann.
I'll even give you a rick Perry.
I'll even give you Sarah Pailin.
I don't have that cynical msnbc point of
view that they are bugged,
nutty batshit crazy.
I think they are good people who somehow
think that their morality and their love
for humanity and their love for their
families are tied up in this weird
tradition and when they think that the
Bible is the word of God,
I think they mean something else.
I sometimes think that many other people
are speaking in a code that I've not
been given.
The key to.
When someone says to me,
I believe in the Bible literally,
well,
I personally pendulum read about a
chapter of the Bible a day.
I just read through it over and over
again,
so when someone says they believe in the
word of God,
literally I go back and think about
genesis where people are living to be
900 years old and I say bullshit and
then I even think about noah and the
flood killing everybody,
God that loves us,
kills everybody and he wants to get two
of every species and several of the ones
that are clean onto a boat that floats
for that amount of time and I just go,
because you don't act that way.
You're able to go to home depot.
You're able to play pay with a credit
card.
You're able to go to starbucks.
You know how to use the computer.
Really.
Do you really mean that?
What do you mean literally?
Do you really mean you're going to stone
someone to death who because they work
on the sabbath or you're really going to
do that?
Really honestly,
you're going to take a rock in your hand
and throw it in a motherfucker's head
because he worked on a Sunday to support
his family or you're really going to do
that if you mix cotton and linen and
your clothing or you're really going to
go to hell.
What do you mean when you say that?
And no one's ever answered me?
There's a cold going on that I need the
Rosetta stone.
I need someone to sit me down and go,
pen put.
Obama says he went to that church and
they talked about all this stuff being
literal.
What he really meant was fill in the
blank,
telling me what is the really mean?
These people are good on this.
Smart.
Not Bad shit.
Crazy people,
so why the fuck are they saying bad
shit?
Crazy stuff to me.